il affirme être venu en Norvège pour
chercher la sécurité après avoir fui le
groupe paramilitaire russe Wagner Andreï
meneve 26 ans a été arrêté par les
gardes norvégiens le 13 janvier c'est
par un petit village situé le long de la
frontière avec la Russie que le jeune
homme est entré en Norvège une évasion
sous le feu des balles de la milice
selon son interview publiée sur le site
de l'ONG russe goulagu quand j'étais sur
la glace j'ai entendu des chiens aboyer
je me suis retourné j'ai vu des gens
avec des torches à environ 150 mètres
courir dans ma direction j'ai entendu
deux coups de feu les balles sont
passées à toute vitesse les autorités
norvégiennes examinent actuellement son
cas
nous n'accordons pas l'asile au
criminels de guerre
il est donc clair qu'il s'agit d'une
évaluation très importante et toutes ces
choses doivent être analysées très
soigneusement
qui est-il
d'où vient-il
ces informations sont-elles etc
nous évaluons tout ça avec toute
personne qui demande l'asile en Norvège
mais il est clair que son cas sera
examiné de manière particulièrement
approfondiener a un rôle clé dans
l'offensive russe en Ukraine maître
affirme l'avoir servi en tant que
commandant d'unité avant de faire
défections prolongé contre son gré au
sein de l'unité et toujours selon ses
dires témoin d'exécution et de
représailles qui auraient motivé sa
fuite l'homme se dit d'ores et déjà prêt
à dire tout ce qu'il sait sur Wagner et
son fondateur
iepheni prigonzine que l'on voit dans
cette vidéo où il prétend accorder
l'amnistie à des condamnés russes en
échange de leur participation au combat
en Ukraine